is a man not entitled to make a video
about ghosts riding people hello
everyone
I don't know why I intro that video that
way but this is Ghost Rider Benjamin
Percy's Ghost Rider part dos and again
Ghost Rider is amazing I love Benjamin
Percy's Ghost Rider run so here's the
thing right in the last video that we
did and really issue number one is kind
of Standalone in fact it's really one of
the first issue number ones that I've
seen coming out of Marvel Comics in
recent years that actually feels
Standalone right you could literally
just pick up that comic and read it and
just be like you know what I'm not
feeling this and that's fine right it's
a great starting off point because it's
designed to rework the score the story
Benjamin Percy's really good at that
kind of stuff what this one does is this
picks up off the heels of that and one
of the cool things about this when it
comes to Ghost Rider is that Benjamin
Percy is returning him to form now the
reason why I say this is that the early
Ghost Rider stories while Ghost Rider
himself was really more built on
Daredevil and in fact transforming what
was Daredevil to a degree and taking the
elements that people liked and turning
it into a more interesting character he
wasn't that dissimilar from The
Incredible Hulk in the sense that Banner
would turn into the Hulk and the Hulk
would turn into Banner but one of the
things about this is that unlike the
banner Hulk dichotomy back in the day
Johnny Blaze was aware of what would
happen when he became the Ghost Rider
now to a degree Benjamin Percy's kind of
modifying that a little bit in the sense
that one of the things that Johnny Blaze
says is sometimes I go dark for hours
for days I don't even know it's hard to
keep track of when let alone where I am
I've got no memory of my clothes burning
off my body I've got no memory of the
bike blazing off the road like a comet
that missed its turn going a thousand
miles per hour I should be dead and even
though every nerve aches like a hot
hangover the worst of it is focused on
my head now the thing about this and
even what he says he says the dotted
line painted on a highway indicates a
fluid division you can travel back and
forth that's how things used to be
between me and the spirit of Vengeance
but now there's more of a solid line as
yellow as sulfur between us I go one way
he goes the other we stay in our lanes
I'm Johnny Blaze or I'm the go Ghost
Rider now this is kind of a again this
is a shift that Benjamin Percy's making
because in years past again just because
of the popularity of the Incredible Hulk
around the time that Johnny Blaze was
introduced that what you saw was a lot
of characters that had this kind of
multiple personality type situation
modeled off the Bruce Banner and
Incredible Hulk relationship but where
Johnny was able to remember who he was
in the past albeit transforming into the
Ghost Rider unwillingly the reality is
it wasn't really him looking at the
world through the Ghost Rider's eyes it
was the two of them working in unison I
mean sure the Ghost Rider would just
kind of do what it wanted to do but
Johnny Blaze wasn't unaware of what was
taking place the reality here is that
with this kind of intermingling of
personalities over the years in Marvel
Comics Johnny Blaze became a character
where he stopped being the guy that
would transform into the Ghost Rider
unwillingly and would actually be the
Ghost Rider most of the time he kind of
started to enjoy what he did punishing
the wicked different things like that
now just different writers
interpretations of the character over
the years some people loved it some
people hated it some people still say
Danny catches the best Ghost Rider which
depending on who you talk to it's kind
of true right the Ghost Rider with like
the Flaming chain all that kind of stuff
that's Danny catch it's one of the funny
things about Ghost Rider when you think
of Ghost Rider in your head you're not
usually thinking of Johnny Blaze you're
thinking of Danny Ketch it's just that
over the years the two have just kind of
become intermingled in terms of how
people identify a particular Ghost Rider
but one of the things that goes on here
is he says apparently he's ended up in
Idaho that he must have been writing for
a week or so so again this is a big
shift the idea that Johnny turns into
the Ghost Rider and has no recollection
of what takes place has no idea of what
goes on but one of the other things to
keep in mind here is we basically end up
transitioning over to agent War Road
with her role in the FBI now remember
Warroad is a relatively new introduction
and in fact as far as I'm aware she's
wholly new to all of this we'll learn a
little more about her as we get through
this story because she's really
fascinating and Truth to tell I really
hope she's not one of these characters
that Marvel just writes out and gets rid
of I really like her character but one
of the the things that goes on is of
course they're basically riding in a
flaming hearse but what's also cool
about this is she actually kind of toys
with the agent to a degree right when
it's just the two of them are kind of
having this banter back and forth and so
one of the things she does as she's
messing with agent Wilmer to a degree is
she kind of gives them a bit of a hard
time now this is kind of normal right
for those of you guys who have ever
found yourself in a new situation like
work school whatever it is the people
who are interested in you usually bust
your balls some people call it
testing whatever the case happens to be
but it's people just kind of giving you
a hard time to see what metal you have
right can you stand up for yourself do
you have some gumption are you the kind
of person that just lets everybody run
over you and so she just starts giving
him a hard time right she's like you
know you're so uptight I bet you're the
kind of guy who doesn't like for his
food to mix I bet you color code your
sock drawer and keep your magazines
alphabetized and you probably have a
ledger full of weird little lists like
the states you've been to or the Sci-Fi
movies you've seen or like your favorite
dinosaurs and that's when he's kind of
like I mean how did you know all that
are you some kind of a Seer and she's
like well I mean I got some spooky stuff
going in my head but I basically broke
into your house as well and then just
look through all your stuff
this is why I love her character man
like it's just she's cool the way that
she operates but what she also does is
she literally climbs into a coffin in
the back of the hearse and then just
kind of Muses to herself and this is why
I say this character's so cool let me
know in the comments if you want to see
more of her this is why her character's
so cool right she says I've always been
different in a way that scares people
second grade I drew a picture that
looked like black scribbles inside of a
walnut when the teacher asked me what it
was I told her it was the cancer inside
her liver she was diagnosed two weeks
later when the other kids went to recess
she kept me inside and slapped me with a
ruler until my cheeks and Knuckles blood
I told my mom she had a baby inside her
before she even had herself tested
before she even peed on a stick and I
told her the same baby was dead before
the nurse confirmed it with an
ultrasound and she says I see bad things
right she's like what's his name from
the success you know she's like I see a
highway that wasn't on any map that
featured flayed bodies crucified to
telephone poles for 10 miles a church
that burned with the congregation still
praying inside a storm of blood that
lasted for five days and flooded a town
a rising Darkness through which a face
keeps flaring into view in the shape of
a flaming skull now here's one of the
reasons why I love this whole
explanation that goes on here Benjamin
Percy is truly bringing Ghost Rider back
to form and the reason why is because
you talk to anybody out there who's been
reading Ghost Rider for say the last 20
years or so you know really since like
the mid-2000s and what they'll tell you
is Marvel drastically tamed Down Johnny
Blaze his story like Ghost Rider's
stories were not interesting and even
when Robbie Reyes became Ghost Writer it
was less like the dark demonic elements
of what made Ghost Rider who he was in
the sense of the stories were like
really dark and twisted and it was more
like I'm Robbie Reyes and I've got a
really tragic backstory and like you
know I'm in ages of shield and here's
some cool stories and it's not to say
his stories were garbage I mean the
Ghost Rider stories on the Robbie Reyes
were pretty fun but it lacked that real
just dark and grittiness right that kind
of hellish sort of landscape that you
associate with a Ghostwriter story it's
one of the things that made us
characters so popular when he was first
introduced and even going throughout the
80s and into the 1990s and so what we
end up doing is picking up with Ghost
Rider inside Idaho or in the state of
Idaho when he checks into just some
really seedy hotel and what he talks
about is that his mind just can't really
focus right that at the moment he really
needs money more than anything else and
so while he's looking at a mirror and
just kind of music to himself we end up
finding out that behind this mirror is
literally a makeshift hallway where you
have a guy that's sort of making his way
through there and looking at each
individual person inside their hotel
room now this guy's not some kind of a
perv although I wouldn't be surprised if
he was to some degree but instead what
it does is it allows him to observe what
are basically his victims the people
that he's going to end up going after so
again one of the ideas behind Ghost
Rider and this is where I'm not entirely
sure did I agree with where Benjamin
Percy's going and we'll talk about that
once we get to that point because I feel
like I understand why Benjamin Percy did
what he did but in truth I feel like it
should have gone in a different
direction but this guy literally just
kind of marks one of the rooms with like
a mom and a dad and a little girl and so
following that of course Johnny Blaze
ends up visiting with him kind of
talking with him and then like look man
I need work right I don't really care
what it is I need some kind of money
I'll scrub toilets I'll do whatever I
have to do man but like I need something
like blood and sweat whatever you need I
could take care of it and so initially
he's put to work just kind of cleaning
up rooms inside the hotel but he finds
little things like like teeth or he
finds what looks like hair and like you
know worms and stuff like that in the
drains he sees some pretty wild stuff
right like bodies that look like they've
been singed into a bet by all standards
the measurement he finds what looks like
basically a murder scene and so as he
bumps into a mirror and as the mirror
falls and shatters and he sees his
reflection as the Ghost Rider in it that
one of the things that's kind of cool
here is he says there's a part of me
that wants to pretend I don't know how
all these broken pieces fit together
because I can already see him sparking
inside me but I've never been one to
drive by an accident I might be able to
swallow down my own pain but I can't
abide seeing others wrestle with hurt
now this matters because in the old
school stories when Ghost Rider First
popped up in Marvel one of the big
caveats of his character is that Johnny
Blaze would turn in into the Ghost Rider
whenever he was in the presence of evil
specifically people who do evil things
right harming others in egregious ways
and so on and so forth and so as
Benjamin Percy again kind of bringing
that back and as he makes his way
through this Corridor he says I know
better than anyone most people have an
outside face the mask they offer to the
world and then an inside face the raw
and naked part of them that they only
reveal behind closed doors sometimes the
inside face is timid and vulnerable
sometimes it's terrifying but it's
always true the dark places are where
the true face hides and so once he gets
into the room where you basically have
the family with a little girl the little
girl's stuffed bunnies Torn to Pieces
the room's covered in blood and that's
what he realizes they've been made
victims and so as soon as that happens
the Ghost Rider Persona manifests right
the spirit of Vengeance takes over and
so what we end up doing is switching
over to the sky when he's inside this
giant Cavern and basically prepares his
family as what are essentially
sacrifices so they're not really dead
yet and so we don't really know where
all the blood came from maybe he just
beat him up really bad or something like
that or cut them a few good times we
don't really know but the truth about
this is that this family is being
sacrificed to this gigantic demonic
entity now this is where I kind of
disagree with what Benjamin Percy's
doing he's building up a kind of giant
demonic story arc right that in the
absence of Ghost Rider in the spirit of
Vengeance these demons are more or less
populating and taking over the world in
different capacities tapping into the
dark wants and desires of humanity and
manipulating them to do their bidding
things along those lines a more classic
Ghost Rider's story would be that this
guy was just twisted and was probably
eating people and like that's it and so
literally Ghost Rider shows up does the
pen and stare makes him feel all the
pain and suffering that he's caused for
everybody that he's ever heard and the
guy goes into a catatonic State and then
Johnny Blazers either burn him alive or
the guy would just die right or he would
just spend his days and as a vegetable
literally as a turnip just sitting in a
hospital somewhere and that would be the
story of him so that would that be a
more traditional Ghost Writer story and
it's kind of what I was hoping we would
get but I'm not overly against what we
end up seeing here because one of the
things this demon does is it immediately
eats the dad like it doesn't hold
anything back right Benjamin Percy's
just like yep he basically consumes this
guy he bites him in half and of course
that leads to the arrival of Ghost Rider
now it's one of these really cool you
get like this amazing moment right you
get this amazing kind of speech where he
says later I would learn this thing's
name it's like a mouth full of
earthworms that cannot be replicated
with words it had been Unearthed long
ago when some miners cracked open its
womb they were hungry for gems for money
it was hungry for blood and Marrow over
the years it found a way to quietly
maintain this balance of appetites money
for blood elk Bears dogs the occasional
human sleeping in an alley a tent or a
parked car but lately it had grown more
bold because the Whispers In the Shadows
told it you have nothing to fear and he
says but the Whispers were wrong the
Shadows lied and he literally points to
the guy and says Penance and that forces
the guy to snap his own neck right to
literally kill himself at that moment
this monster recognizes Johnny Blaze and
it realizes Johnny Blaze is back and
that's why you have this interaction
between them where because Johnny Blaze
was being kept in Hayden Falls which was
basically a town that was operated by
demons albeit allowing Johnny's storm to
be removed from the world as a whole
every other demon out there saw it as
their chance to do their own thing and
they were all informed that was the case
right Johnny Blaze is being held as a
prisoner in his own mind over here so
it's open season for you guys go and do
whatever you want to do and they were
relishing in that right they were having
the time of their lives manipulating
humanity and so on and so forth and
that's why it says like you were
supposed to be extinguished you were
supposed to be gone your time is
supposed to be over and our time is
supposed to be now and the response of
Ghost Rider is let it be known I ride
again and in doing so kills that guy on
the spot and so following this you
switch back over to War Road and to
Wilmer and they basically end up pulling
a U-turn and following a uh following a
fire truck to literally literally to
where this hotel is and as they get
there they start hearing people saying
things like it was a man with a flaming
skull he made everybody do this all that
kind of stuff and so that's when you
have War Road who makes this makes this
deal right this idea that she's going to
avenge actually find Johnny Blaze the
irony behind all this is she doesn't
know that Johnny Blaze is really more of
a hero than a traditional villain but
just the nature of Ghost Rider itself is
that he's more akin to like the Punisher
albeit for like exceedingly violent
people that the Punisher wouldn't
normally be able to handle right demons
or different things like that and so War
Road doesn't have the bigger picture so
that's why I say I really hope this
turns into her becoming a far more
involved character in The Ghost Rider
Mythos because I'm curious to see what
happens when she figures out what's
actually going on but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you all for watching and
I will catch you all later
peace